[Music]
welcome back so we've been talking about
sparsity and compressed sensing and how
different norms give you different
solutions to underdetermined systems of
equations so now I want to illustrate
these ideas in code in Python okay so
specifically what we're what we're
dealing with here is this
under-determined system of equations y
equals theta s and we have essentially a
small measurement vector Y and a high
dimensional unknown vector s and we're
going to solve for s that satisfies this
equations okay this system of equations
so we know that this could come from the
compress sensing problem where we have y
equals some matrix c times some matrix
sy times some vector s where sy times s
may be x is a high dimensional vector
representing an image so a million
dimensional vector in pixel space s
could be its Fourier transform so a
sparse million dimensional vector in
Fourier domain would be s and C would be
this sparse measurement operator that
would measure individual pixels of our
high dimensional image X and and so Y
would be a subsample of maybe 10% of the
pixels in our high dimensional image X
and we're trying to find the sparse
vector s in the Fourier domain that is
consistent with those measurements okay
so generally speaking Y is a known
measurement theta is a known matrix and
s is an unknown vector that we're trying
to solve for and we want s to be as
sparse as possible at least for the
compressed sensing problem okay and so
the setup here is pretty simple we we
measure Y we we know what theta is and
we're gonna solve for s and there are
many different ways of solving for s
because this Y vector is small in fact
here we're going to set this up in
Python so that my my S vector and my X
vector are a thousand dimensional okay
so n is a thousand the dimension of s my
output measurement Y is 200 dimensional
so I'm only been measuring twenty
percent
of this this high dimensional vector X
so why is two hundred dimensional s as a
thousand dimensional and so what that
means is that this system of equations
is under determined there's not enough
information in Y to uniquely determine a
solution s in fact there are in general
infinitely many solutions the s that
would possibly solve this system of
equations and so we have an enormous
choice out of all of these infinitely
many solutions s which one do we choose
to solve for this equation okay and so
there's lots of different ways of
solving for these and I'm going to work
out two variations here we're gonna
we're gonna show the least square
solution this is kind of the solution
you're used to that you you would
usually solve for in an underdetermined
system of equations you would basically
try to satisfy offer an S that satisfies
this equation an S this satisfies this
equation here that has the minimum l
2-norm on s that has basically the
smallest radius of s in its high
dimensional vector space the smallest
norm of s so so that would be one
solution is the minimum l 2-norm
solution or the least square solution
and you would solve for this by
computing the pseudo inverse of theta
and multiplying it by Y so you pseudo
inverse theta and you'd say s equals
pseudo inverse of theta times y this
pseudo inverse just for those of you who
are interested you would compute this
using the singular value decomposition
which is in Chapter one and another
another video series
you take the SVD of theta and then you
invert each matrix matrix by matrix and
that would be easy because those
matrices are unitary and diagonal okay
but long story short you can compute the
minimum two norm solution s that
satisfies this equation but what we're
interested in for compressed sensing and
for sparsity we want the spar cyst
vector s possible and so what we
actually want to do is minimize the l1
norm of s because I've told you before
that if we find an S that has a really
really small l1 norm it's probably going
to be a sparse vector so the l1 norm
promotes sparsity and the way we do that
is we try to find the minimum
one norm of s such that y equals theta s
is true okay that's how we write this as
an optimization problem we want to find
them we want to find s that has the
minimum one norm but still satisfies
this equation okay so I'm gonna code up
both of these in Python we're gonna run
it and we're gonna see what it what
answer we get okay this is gonna take a
little while generally to run these
optimizations in Python okay good so we
set up the problem here we have our
theta matrix which is a Gaussian random
matrix of size P by n and Y is also a
random randomly sampled vector basically
I don't need these to be anything but
random and I can still because it's an
underdetermined system I can still solve
for sparse s this satisfies this okay
and then to find the l1 norm solution
here what we're gonna do is this is
relatively simple we're gonna define the
l1 norm and then we're going to minimize
the l1 norm with an initial condition
using this SL sqp optimization algorithm
with the constraints given in this
constraints line up here okay and you
can download this code from data book
eww calm and kind of work through all of
these and you know look look through
each line by line but basically what
we're doing is we're solving this
minimization here we're finding the
minimum one norm vector s that satisfies
this system of equations okay and that's
what I'm saying here so we want theta X
minus y to be minimized to be equal to
zero and we want to minimize the one
norm good so I'm going to run all of
this and it might take a little while
yep still thinking and then it's also
really really easy to find the least
square solution by just computing the P
inverse the pseudo inverse of theta
times y so this is kind of a built-in
function the pseudo inverse into nun
PI's linear algebra package so NPL in
algae inverse gets this and then you can
multiply it by your Y vector to get the
least squares s
okay so my l1 norm solution is still
thinking this doesn't you know this is
not super fast to run these
optimizations but it is eventually going
to converge so it's going to minimize
the l1 and apparently I initialize this
with the least square solution so I'm
starting from the the l2 solution as my
initialization and then we run this
minimization to converge to the l1
minimum solution now I've actually run
this ahead of time so I'm just going to
show you what these plots kind of the
output while this is running and I'm
gonna plot everything all at once so
what we have here kind of on this top
plot right here is the l1 solution and
next to it what we have is the l2
solution okay and the top plot the blue
plot and the red plot have a thousand
elements and so this is literally a plot
of s of the entries of s you know s1 s2
s3 s4 all the way up to s 1000 and the
same thing in red here for the least
square solution and so right off the bat
what you notice is that the least square
solution most of these values are much
much smaller but almost all of them are
nonzero so this does have a smaller kind
of radius in the l2 sense but it doesn't
have sparsity at all these are very very
non sparse solutions in red in blue this
s vector it's a little hard to see on
this screen but these values are much
much larger and they're much spicier and
if you zoomed in what you would find is
that most of these values are zero and
occasionally they spike up to these
large values then they go down to zero
then they spike down to a large value
and so this blue solution that solved
the one norm is very sparse most of its
entries are zero and you can see that
here in these histograms these are
literally histograms or counts of how
many of the values of s were 0 or 0.5 or
0.1 or negative 0.05 and things like
that for the least squares and for the
l1 solutions and so what you see here is
that in the least squared solution
most of these values are distributed
away from 0 so most of the values are
nonzero which is what you expect
from the least square solution but in
the l1 solution there's this huge peak
here at at zero and what this shows you
is that almost all of the values of this
s factor are very very nearly zero and
then only a small number of them only a
couple hundred are distributed out here
far away from zero and this actually
makes sense because remember this small
vector Y had 200 entries and this large
unknown vector s had 1,000 entries and
so I can solve this system of equations
with approximately 200 nonzero entries
in s so I can probably find a solution
to this with 200 nonzero entries of s
and about 800 zero entries and that's
almost exactly what we see here this is
0 200 400 600 the top would be about 800
and so what we have here is almost
exactly 800 zero entries in s and the
rest of this system of equations is
being solved with those other 200
nonzero entries so this effectively
shows that when you do this minimization
meant penalizing the one norm of s you
get a very very sparse solution but we
do penalize the two norm which is the
least square solution your your a
specter is not sparse at all ok so
that's something I really really wanted
to show you is this idea that for these
underdetermined systems of equations
there are multiple solutions both of
these solutions actually satisfy the
system of equations
but only by penalizing the one norm do
you actually recover a sparse solution
where most of the entries of s are 0 ok
thank you